I'm Greg Jarrett I'm Sandra Smith I'm
Charles Payne and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday October 19th 2022 and Lisa
Brady the midterm races are in the home
stretch and a close one is in North
Carolina I like to say it's the NASCAR
State and that you don't let off the gas
until you see the checkered flag and
we're not going to let up for the next
three weeks I'm Dave Anthony there is
growing concern China might invade
Taiwan forcing the U.S to make a choice
let China take it or go to war we either
lose all our credibility which is going
to cost lives down the road or a lot of
Americans die right up front that's why
it's so critical a thousand times more
critical than with Ukraine that we
prevent this war from ever happening and
I'm David Marcus I've got the final word
on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
if Democrats keep control of Congress
President Biden says the first bill
he'll send to lawmakers would make
abortion rights federal law after the
Supreme Court's overturning of Roe
versus Wade and when Congress passes it
I'll sign it in January 50 years after
Roe was first decided the law of the
land the president's promise made at a
DNC event Tuesday even as the economy
and inflation Remain the top concern for
many midterm voters the president's
going to continue to talk about issues
that matter to the American people and
abortion is one of them majority of the
American people disagree with the
decision that that the Supreme Court
made spokeswoman Kareem Jean-Pierre says
the president is working on the economy
every day Republicans say his policies
are the problem fueling higher prices
you know I'm hearing about it in very
real terms not like a college professor
would talk about it North Carolina
congressman Ted Budd is a republican
running for Senate against Democrat
Sherry Beasley former Chief Justice of
the state supreme court the longtime
incumbent Republican senator Richard
Burr is retiring I mean just the best
example is
um you know there's a lady that commutes
in from outside of Raleigh he's six
months away from retirement and she says
I don't know if I can afford gas in my
car to get to my job to get to my
retirement and then maybe six weeks ago
kids were getting back in school parents
were wondering I don't know how I'm
going to buy back to school clothes a
new backpack and pay for my power bill
and groceries on the table and gas in my
car so I mean they're talking about it
in very real terms and and they know I
mean these are people that they aren't
intrinsically political but they're
saying why are we no longer an energy
exporter why are we not energy Surplus
in our country why would Joe Biden you
know months ago or a year and a half ago
kill the Keystone Pipeline and they they
feel the repercussions of everything
that Joe Biden has done and you know
they're looking at this race and they go
they're thinking that Sherry Beasley is
just a rubber stamp for Joe Biden's
policy so why would I want to support
her what about spending because that's
something that
um you know many of your Republican
colleagues have said is really helping
to fuel inflation and
some fiscal conservatives have
complained that Republicans spent too
much when they controlled the House and
Senate why should voters trust that
wouldn't happen again
well I'm a fiscal conservative I can't
speak for everyone but I can know that I
voted against those big spending bills
and let's go back to what inflation is
you know it's too much money chasing too
few goods I think that was Milton
Friedman who said that and so when you
pop too much money into the economy but
I can tell you what Joe Biden's done he
calls these things like the American
Rescue plan which pumped nearly two
trillion dollars in the economy which
weren't it wasn't necessary at the time
we were on a v-shaped recovery when he
dumped it right in on top of that and
then he does these things like so-called
inflation reduction act which it does
nothing of the sort it just helps rich
people buy Teslas it's completely out of
touch it fuels the green New Deal it
makes energy more expensive so
everything Joe Biden does is about
spending and making it harder on people
not just in North Carolina but around
the whole country and and people are
sick of it they know I mean people have
become well-educated economists when
they're looking at their price of their
grocery bill and their power bill and
their their fuel bill at the gas station
right behind inflation as a top concern
in the latest Fox News polling is crime
some something that
voter surveyed give Republicans a
double-digit edge on in terms of
handling it how would you address Rising
crime around the country
well you have to look at both sides of
it and it's two issues but they merge
together under crime and that's the
border which we have the cartel
trafficking of drugs and Fentanyl
product and primary ingredients coming
from China through Mexico and Fentanyl
across our border traffic by the cartels
human trafficking coming right in here
and we're seeing three and a half four
million since people that's just the
known people and then we have the
gotaways that have come through our
borders and then we have about close to
a hundred now uh just under 100 that are
on the terrorist watch list and that was
uh maybe one or two under President
Trump so it's it's just infuriating
because when I was down there the
Customs and Border Patrol agents they
said we just need an Administration in
Washington that has our back and they
don't have that under Joe Biden and then
when I come here to North Carolina we've
got a hundred counties sheriffs law
enforcement are coming up to me around
the state and they say every single
county in North Carolina is now a border
County because of Joe Biden policies and
they realized that my opponent Sherry
Beasley would be a complete rubber stamp
I mean this is a person that on the
bench she defended cop killers she threw
out indictments for sex offenders she
has let child Predators get out with on
parole without GPS tracking let them get
back on social media and I don't know
why she's chosen to uh you know
take this different path but it's bad
and it's scaring parents to death so
whether it's violent crime locally or
whether that's at the border it's all
come home to roost for the Democrats bad
policies I know you're endorsed by
multiple law enforcement groups
including the Fraternal Order of Police
the police benevolent Association just
to name two Beasley's counter to that is
that you voted against funding for law
enforcement in the house what were those
votes about
well when you take talk about spending
from a topic or two ago in this
conversation when Nancy Pelosi shoves
these fake messaging bills on the floor
which has billions sometimes of spending
which has very little to do with law
enforcement and then they put just a
smidgen of funding in there for law
enforcement the big bills that come
through the things that protect our
police those are the things I'm for but
clearly my opponent has done fundraisers
with the leader of the depot and the
police movement she's got a bad record
and my record has been consistent but if
Nancy Pelosi puts out this show vote
just to give our members some cover and
Sherry Beasley some cover people in
North Carolina aren't buying it they're
looking at everybody from the the one I
would add to that is the North Carolina
Troopers Association the people that put
the men and women in uniform to put
their lives on the line every day with
law enforcement the police benevolent
Association Fraternal Order of Police
and all the way down to the border the
national border patrol Association has
just been
hugely supportive of me because they
know I've got their back we also reached
out to be Beasley's campaign and didn't
get a response but speaking to Fox News
recently she stood by her record as a
judge working with law enforcement and
criticizing Bud's record in Congress
well Congress and Bud has voted with his
party 92 percent of the time and you
know I have always vowed to be
independent I'm gonna
stand for what's right I'm going to call
out what's wrong and I'm going to leave
courageously both candidates have had
support from outside spending liberal
politician Beasley is come for you and
your wallet but Beasley's campaign
raised almost three times as much as
Bud's campaign in the most recent
quarter so is the congressman concerned
about having enough funding to hit the
Finish Line strong well the answer in
politics has always won just a little
bit more and we would love for folks to
go to tedbud.com and support we would
certainly put every penny to good use
here because the Democrats have wasted
so much money they have a bad habit of
wasting money here in North Carolina but
we want to make sure that we are smart
in how we get our message out and stay
humble work hard and ask for people's
votes and that's that's why we have a
slight Edge and again we're always
within the margin of error here in North
Carolina and we have to keep working
hard for the next three weeks Senator
Burr who held the seat for nearly two
decades and is not running for
re-election voted to impeach former
president Trump You by contrast one
Trump's endorsement in the GOP Primary
for this seat that connection can be a
double-edged sword sometimes
um do you do people ask you about Trump
or his policies as you've been
campaigning or is it not part of the
conversation for the general election
they ask me all the time and it reminded
that Trump won North Carolina twice I'm
honored to have received his endorsement
last year it's been a huge help but
let's go back to why he endorsed me he
endorsed me because I'm an America First
candidate and I've never wavered on
those policies those are the policies
that led to 1.4 inflation not Joe Biden
and Sherry Beasley eight or nine percent
inflation it led to low crime uh reduced
fentanyl deaths it led to the lowest
unemployment in history for women people
of color and Hispanics and we have to
get back to those policies that made us
a greater and greater Nation the
president keeps highlighting the issue
of abortion saying that it's a it's a
key issue for this election
um is that an issue that could help to
decide this this Senate race in your
state well the recent polling it shows
that more and more women are deciding to
support my uh candidacy and I'm very
honored to receive that but let's talk
about how extreme the Democrats are on
this abortion issue they're way out of
touch with North Carolina because they
believe in abortion at any time for any
reason at taxpayer expense all the way
up until the moment of birth and if you
pulled North Carolinians that's not
where they are men or women it seems
like each party kind of leaves out the
fine print on each other's positions on
abortion though I mean you know
Democrats accuse Republicans of wanting
a national ban for instance is that
something that you would support I've
been pro-life long before I was ever in
politics but I've always been very
consistent about protecting the life of
a woman and uh and again I just wish
that she would be a little more honest
when she describes my opinion
historically speaking North Carolina
tends to elect Republican Senators this
is considered a fairly close race though
the Fox News Power Rankings have a lean
Republican how are you feeling with less
than three weeks to go I like to say
it's the NASCAR State and that you don't
let off the gas until you see the
checkered flag and we're not going to
let up for the next three weeks you want
to stay humble work hard stay focused
ask for people's votes and we believe
that'll get us across the finish line
but again you're never comfortable in
North Carolina it's always close
if there's one thing if there's one
message that you think maybe voters
aren't getting or aren't hearing
from you what would it be what would you
want them to hear I'd just like them to
know that everything that I have done
everything that I will do is about
making their life better right here in
our nation and in North Carolina and
then everything that Sherry Beasley has
done and will do makes life worse for us
in North Carolina and that she is a
rubber stamp for Joe Biden's policies
North Carolina Republican congressman
Ted Budd running for Senate good luck
with the campaign thanks for joining us
thanks so much for having me it's a
great day
this is David Marcus with your Fox News
commentary coming up
is Taiwan the next Ukraine
China's leader more than hinted at it
over the weekend
as the wheels of History roll forward
towards National reunification and the
Revival of the nation the complete
reunification of the motherland must be
achieved and can definitely be achieved
and president Xi Jinping went further
than that in his speech to the Chinese
Communist Party Congress which will give
him another five-year term at office he
would not rule out reunification by
force taking over Taiwan which considers
itself an independent nation with its
own government and Military and
Republican Congressman Michael Waltz
says China could invade within five
years so the question is are we running
out of time from the United States
standpoint to deter that from happening
Waltz tells Fox G's goal is becoming the
dominant Global superpower on his watch
and replacing the American dream with
the China dream Waltz is just back from
a trip to Taiwan as part of a bipartisan
delegation that include did Congressman
Seth Moulton who is also worried about
the threats it's a huge concern now it's
not a surprise I think that those of us
who have been watching China and Taiwan
closely recognizing the risk there
Congressman Moulton is a Democrat from
Massachusetts Xi Jinping wants to take
over Taiwan and and let's be clear
reunification is his euphemism for
saying invade the free country of Taiwan
and put them under his authoritarian
communist rule take away their democracy
take away their freedoms that's what Xi
Jinping wants to do and he's up the
stakes because now he says he's going to
do it soon so he also refused to rule
out doing this by force you know
Invasion so clearly there's no other way
is there it's not like taiwan's gonna
pick up the phone and say hey let's
unify
nobody in Taiwan wants this there's a
reason why the people there are
independent and have a democracy which
of course the people in mainland China
do not have
there were some apologists I think for
the Chinese regime who said maybe
there's some compromise we could work
out but once they saw what Xi Jinping
did to Hong Kong that's all over No One
Believes that anymore yeah because now
China has its thumb right on Hong Kong
China has crushed Taiwan in fact Xi
Jinping bragged about it in his speech
about how he's put down the protests
viciously and violently so everyone who
is hoping that there would be some sort
of one country two systems and Hong Kong
would maintain the freedom that the
people of Hong Kong have experienced for
a generation well that's out the window
and the people of Taiwan see that very
clearly why now though I mean Taiwan has
been independent so what is why the
urgency from China to do this well you
know it's always a little dangerous to
make close comparisons among different
countries but China and Russia have a
lot of similarities here they're both
led by autocratic
self-aggrandizing leaders who want to
make a legacy for themselves
and they're both running into economic
problems at home Russia more immediately
but China is running up against the wall
where they're not going to be able to
grow the way they have so I think Putin
and Xi Jinping are both looking ahead
and saying we're not going to have an
economic Legacy here we're going to have
Rising discontent at home a way to
establish a legacy is to be like a
conqueror of old and take over another
country that's what Putin is doing in
Ukraine and that's what Xi Jinping wants
to do with Taiwan so Taiwan has a
military a forces something like 300
000. that's a tough match for China
isn't it I mean that's just not enough
to stop China and that's why America has
two terrible options if China invades
either we just say you know what we were
kidding we're not actually going to help
you Taiwan you're just going to fall to
China and if we do that our credibility
will be shot around the globe we'll go
through from peace through strength to
War through weakness and that will cost
a lot of American lives for decades to
come all right well hold on one second
what if we do like Ukraine where we say
we will promise to help defend you
here's a bunch of weapons here's air
defense here's all of this like we're
doing with Ukraine well that's a great
question Dave but it's not an option
because we can't come after the fact to
Taiwan it's an island China is going to
blockade it off we can't give them
weapons after the fact we can't just
support them through a proxy we don't
have any way to do that all right now
you said the other option which is also
bad right so the other option is that we
do in fact just say no you're not going
to invade and that means we start taking
out the Chinese Invasion force that
means they start shooting our Navy and
that's sadly a lot of Americans are
going to die if that happens that's war
that is war that's war with China That's
war with the greatest national security
threat that we face in the coming
decades a greater threat than Russia
with a more advanced military better
technology and the willingness to use it
so those are the two terrible options we
either lose all our credibility which is
going to cost lives down the road or a
lot of Americans die right up front
that's why it's so critical a thousand
times more critical than with Ukraine
that we prevent this war from ever
happening that our deterrence is so
effective that Xi Jinping says
nope I'm gonna lose so I'm not going to
evade but what what is this deterrence
sanctions whatever what what what would
possibly deter China well I I think that
the sanctions regime we've been able to
put together against Russia is
impressive but at the end of the day
what's going to stop China is our
military it's the military threat it's
Xi Jinping looking out and seeing the
United States with all of our Democratic
allies in the Pacific so United against
an invasion of Taiwan that he says he's
just going to lose that he's going to
lose like Putin is losing right now in
Ukraine and he doesn't even try but one
of the things we were looking at in on
our trip here is the strategy we're
being briefed in Washington to
strengthen our deterrence in the Pacific
is that actually being implemented on
the ground so we met we met troops we
talked to the folks who were actually
carrying this out another question we
asked is are our partners those allies
that are all have always been our
strength are they ready to be with us in
this fight I think the results of that
were pretty mixed the third question was
how are we translating this preparation
for war preparation to win a war against
China how are we Translating that into
deterrence and I'll tell you what the
answers are pretty sobering we have a
lot of work to do when you talked to
taiwan's president obviously China when
house Speaker Pelosi went in August
they you know the war games military
exercises and and really very angry
about that trip
how nervous
are the people of Taiwan as the
president
they are very concerned they're
concerned about how quickly this could
happen and whether or not they're really
going to be prepared in time we're
concerned about that whether we are
going to be prepared in time
because we might be in a position to
convince Xi Jinping he's going to lose
this war we might be in a position to do
that in 2035 but if he decides to invade
in a couple years that's not going to
make a difference we've got to be ready
sooner and that's the urgency that I
think we all feel having returned from
this trip what if he did it soon knowing
that a lot of the world is focused on
helping Ukraine still and the United
States is focused on helping Ukraine
still and suddenly we have to worry
about that I mean this is look it's a
dangerous world out there we can't take
our eye off the ball like we're doing
the right thing in Ukraine it's critical
for the defense of Europe and we've got
to continue doing it but we got to do
more in the Pacific at the same time was
President Biden right when he asked was
answered few several times in the last
year that the U.S would defend Taiwan
American forces defend Taiwan was he
right with that
I think he's right I think the
Republican Congressman here might
actually agree with Biden more on this
point than I do I'm a little bit more
hesitant but you know this is one of the
values going on this trip is not only do
you see things you get to talk more to
your colleagues and and Congressman
Wallace has made I think a strong case
to me that it may be time to move to a
position of strategic Clarity where
we're just unambiguous yes China if you
invade we're going to stop you in
November Congressman Seth Moulton is
hoping to win a fifth term in
Massachusetts sixth house district he
faces a challenge from Republican Bob
may but is favored that race not among
the 33 toss-ups in the Fox News Power
Rankings but even if Moulton is
re-elected Democrats could lose a bunch
of other seats so he knows it's quite
possible and widely projected
Republicans could win control of the
house maybe even the senate in the next
Congress sure yes I mean I am concerned
I'm I'm I'm working hard not just on my
own re-election but uh to support
especially veterans especially
Democratic veterans running across the
country I have an organization called
serve America that I established to do
just that but we can't let politics get
in the way of National Security we can't
let politics divert us from doing our
fundamental job which is protecting the
American people and I think that's
something that especially veterans
understand on both sides of the aisle
yeah and and it would let's say your
party doesn't keep control of at least
the house or or the senator or you know
or both
what are Taiwan policy and what happens
in Taiwan and China do you think that
would matter
well it's a good question because of
course traditionally we've always
thought of the Republican party as more
hawkish more supportive of the military
of course it was Reagan who built up the
military to such strength during the the
1980s in the Cold War right that's right
and in contrast we usually think of the
Democrats as the ones who want to cut
defense budgets but those divisions
aren't so clear anymore because it's the
very conservative wing of the Republican
party that's been much more isolationist
that said we shouldn't be supporting
Ukraine as much as we have been that's
saying that we shouldn't get involved in
a conflict over Taiwan and of course
it's a Democratic president President
Biden who's had the strongest statements
in the defense of Taiwan uh of any
American president ever so the lines are
blurring you said you're in the middle
what about the hard left within your
party that's a concern as well I mean
that you know it's funny they find
themselves in an awkward position with
Ukraine because they've always been kind
of anti-military and now of course
they're supporting Ukraine and and they
sometimes choose to ignore the fact that
it's our defense budgets that they
always vote against which of course are
providing that Aid so you know again
this is the Extremes in either party
that are risk here I I think we we got
to end this craziness it's it's getting
a little bit obscene Democratic
Congressman Seth Moulton from
Massachusetts just back from his trip to
Taiwan thank you very much for joining
us thank you Dave
[Music]
and in other news I'm Gian Angel Losi
it's October and that means Halloween is
upon us and even if we adults aged out
of trick-or-treating candy is still one
of the big draws of the holiday but when
it comes to favorite candy we are a
nation divided at least according to
grocery service instacart it calculated
the top candies based on the weight of
each candy sold during October of 2021
and found Reese's Peanut Butter Cups
Reigns Supreme more than 116 tons were
sold coming in second peanut M M's with
92 tons sold instacart's data dug even
deeper revealing where you are most
likely to find either of the Rival
peanutty chocolatey treats the East
Coast West Coast rival receipts even
into our suites with peanut M M's
ranking most popular on the west coast
Reese's Peanut Butter Cups dominating
the East Coast the two exceptions are
Hawaii and New Hampshire which shows
Eminem's as their favorite Halloween
candy a poll in September found 82
percent of Americans buy Halloween candy
whether or not they even like Halloween
Utah a pair currently has the biggest
Sweet Tooth other states that bought the
most candy Idaho Alaska Montana
Washington states with the lowest share
of candy purchases were Florida Delaware
Alabama North Carolina and South
Carolina 63 percent of Americans report
they now love a Halloween candy they
hated as a kid like 29 of people who say
they like licorice now 28 say they even
developed an affinity for candy corn on
the other hand 59 now say they hate a
type of Halloween candy they loved as a
kid 27 percent grew out of their candy
corn phase 21 now dislike chewing gum
and sour candy and if you still need a
costume idea instacart says the top
costume sold in 2021 were peanut butter
and jelly couples costumes hippie
costumes and a banana costume for the
Fox News rundown I'm Gianna jalosi
precise personal powerful is America's
weather team in the palm of your hands
get Fox weather updates throughout your
busy day every day subscribe and listen
now at foxnewspodcast.com or wherever
you get your podcasts raid and review
the Fox News rundown on Apple podcasts
or wherever you listen it's time for
your Fox News commentary David Marcus
what's on your mind it seems that Jon
Stewart has learned absolutely nothing
over the past two years in a stunning
interview with Arkansas attorney general
Leslie Rutledge about proposed laws to
restrict the medical gender
transitioning of kids the former funny
man actually asked you're suggesting
that protecting children means
overriding the recommendations of the
American Medical Association yes John
that is what is being suggested why
because it was the AMA and the rest of
the alphabet soup of medical advocacy
organizations that supported school
closing masking kids and a host of other
restrictions that we now know harms
millions of them they should have been
over rule then and must be questioned
now all throughout the pandemic
lockdowns we heard it's not about
politics it's about science that was and
is a steaming bag of utter nonsense of
course it was about politics when broad
Public Health policies like school
closures are pushed into place the
ramifications affect all of society and
as such they are political not merely
medical decisions this is true of
so-called gender affirming care as well
that's because such medical procedures
are about more than individuals and
their doctors in fact such treatment
requires that all of society buy into
the metaphysical proposition that people
can change gender and requires opening
women's sports gender-specific spaces
and all the rest to obey the AMA and its
allies like Stuart
there's another similarity at work here
from the earliest days of covid-19 we
knew its risk to Children was extremely
small in order to protect a tiny
vulnerable population our experts opted
to harm almost all children likewise in
order to protect a tiny fraction of kids
with extreme gender dysphoria who were
allegedly at risk of self-harm without
affirmation all cases must be affirmed
according to a recent study the number
of children diagnosed with gender
dysphoria in our country left from
roughly 21 000 in 2019 to 42 000 in 2021
doubling in just two years whether this
increase is a result of social contagion
greater acceptance or anything else it
is folly to affirm every child who
expresses any gender confusion at a
tender age thousands and thousands of
kids who may well have grown out of
dysphoria naturally will be plunged into
the lucrative assembly line of gender
transformation many in ways that cannot
be reversed more broadly all of us and
all of our children churches and Co
culture will be brow beaten into the
acceptance of a non-binary concept of
gender that most Americans reject if
Stewart wants to sit there with the
little look on his face mugging to
obedient fans about how Superior they
all are to ignorant Republicans that's
his business but given what we have so
recently gone through at the hands of
these wise experts he looks like an
absolute fool it was George William
Russell who wisely wrote long ago that
experts should be on tap not on top of
course we must listen to and weigh what
they say but this time we must listen to
all of the experts thank you very much
not just the ones wearing expensive
institutional blinders do not let
Stewart or anyone else tell you that if
you aren't a specifically selected
doctor you have no say in the questions
of children and gender we saw the Havoc
wrought by such thinking during covet
19. America is not a tyranny of
expertise and Americans must never allow
it to become one
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
Jason in the house that Jason Chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as I take on American
Life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you download podcasts